anyone thinking these scenes are in
china could be forgiven
it's actually a kovit 19 vaccine center
for chinese nationals
living and working in sri lanka they
were the first to receive vaccines from
the 600 000 doses
donated to the south asian island by
beijing
we started to give only for the chinese
citizens who are living here
working and living in the families and
those who are working in in
sri lanka after i put the vaccine i feel
very normal i don't have any heart
feelings
so for now i feel good but these
reactions are not enough for sri lanka's
regulator
the national medicines regulatory
authority to clear the use of cyanopharm
on locals
it's demanding more data before making a
decision
we have to go with the scientific
evidence and then only
give the approval for anything like
whether it's a diagnostic method or drug
or
vaccine so it is same for the sign of
ammo so
if the if good data is available
regarding the efficacy and the safety
then there's no problem
we'll have to that but without those
data definitely we cannot tap through
because we can't risk of giving
something to our people
of which we are not sure the delays
causing displeasure within the
government
both president gotaber and his brother
mahindra rajapaksa
have worked closely with china in recent
years
the president received the shipment of
vaccines from the chinese ambassador in
colombo
when it arrived last week in the feist
against the pandemic our two countries
and the two peoples have been
always standing formally together
and extending a helping hand to each
other
we face many difficulties during last
two to three weeks to bring this to sri
lanka
due to certain unexpected
influences from various parties however
we overcome all these influences and
ultimately
make it a success not quite
as the regulatory authority refused to
be pushed to grant approval
the government removed seven of its 13
board members
describing it as a move to reform the
body
but a senior doctor claimed their
removal was connected to the cyanopharm
vaccine
at a time when coveted vaccines around
the world are coming under scrutiny
regulators here say they cannot approve
the sign of armed dose
until they study all necessary data
they say the sooner they receive this
the sooner they can make
a decision minil fernandez al jazeera
colombo